anja günther ist uns zugeschaltet
ministerpräsident von schleswig holstein
und mitglied im präsidium der cdu guten
abend herr günther enorm frau slomka
die junge union stellt die parteichefin
in frage herr märz stellt die kanzlerin
in frage was ist denn da los in der cdu
ist das der beginn einer revolte
nein das glaube ich nicht
ich glaube das ist ein bisschen der
falsche zeitpunkt solche debatten
überhaupt zu führen denn wir haben ja
keine ungeklärten führungsfragen sondern
wir haben eine parteivorsitzende gewählt
ist wir haben die bundeskanzlerin und
von daher sehe ich das eigentlich
relativ gelassen
aber ich habe schon ein bisschen déjà vu
wenn ich mir angucke wie es mit der spd
angefangen hat wie sie in den umfragen
immer weiter runter gegangen ist genauso
in dem sie sich mit sich selbst
beschäftigt indem sie erfolge der
vergangenheit klein und teilweise
schlecht redet genau das versuchen im
moment einige von der seitenlinie aus
unsere kanzlerin angela merkel hat vier
bundestagswahlen erfolgreich für die
union beschrittene bestritten und von
daher ist meine herzliche bitte an alle
diese sperrfeuer einzustellen und
denjenigen die verantwortung zu
überlassen die im moment gewählt sind
sagt friedrich merz ist kann so nicht
weitergehen und bezieht sich darauf die
wahlergebnisse jetzt das debakel in
thüringen aber vorher in sachsen
brandenburg oder bei der europawahl
liebst ja auch nicht besser
hat er da nicht ein punkt zu sagen wir
sind ja auf einer abschüssigen rampe und
da muss was geschehen mir aber ich
glaube dass die zeit wo man einfach mit
standardfloskeln wahlergebnisse
kommentiert hat einfach vorbei sind was
hilft es uns zu sagen so kann es nicht
weitergehen
das bestreitet ja keiner wenn man eine
landtagswahl wie in thüringen bestreitet
wo die union nur drittstärkste kraft
wird da gibt es keinen der sagt es war
jetzt ja alles richtig gelaufen und
jetzt haben wir halt so ein ergebnis
sondern natürlich müssen wir besser
werden müssen wir auch besser
kommunizieren aber müssen wir eben auch
ein bisschen stärker
wie der politische inhalte nach draußen
kehren wo die menschen sagen dafür trägt
die union verantwortung dafür arbeiten
wir gut und ohne zweifel ist thüringen
ohne
nicht denkbar ein so schlechtes ergebnis
sondern die performance der
bundesregierung hat ihr übriges dazu
beigetragen aber genau das ist einfach
eben nicht mit solchen er sagt ja
untätigkeit der kanzlerin als er
argumentiert ja durchaus inhaltlich naja
inhaltlicher nicht sondern er sagt es
darf so nicht weitergehen
und es ist doch ohne zweifel so dass die
bundesregierung im moment kein gutes
image bei der bevölkerung hat aber es
kann uns doch auch nicht wundern wenn
die politischen parteien die
bundesregierung tragen
über ihre eigene arbeit schlecht reden
in zweifel ziehen ob eine
bundesregierung überhaupt weiter regiert
wir können auch von den menschen auf der
straße nicht erwarten dass sie unsere
arbeit gut finden wenn wir sie setzt
nicht gut finden wenn wir uns selbst zur
disposition stellen
und wenn union und spd nicht endlich
lernen dass wenn man politische
verantwortung trägt man diese
verantwortung auch positiv nach draußen
war neben bus muss sich um die
herausforderungen der menschen zu wird
sich wirklich kümmern muss wenn wir das
nicht gemeinsam lernen
wer dann werden union und spd insgesamt
aus diesem strudel nicht rauskommt darum
müssen wir uns kümmern und das ist die
aufgabe die wir auch als union haben
dann schauen wir uns das aber mal
strategisch an also warum sagt herr merz
dass es kann so zwei jahre lang so nicht
weitergehen offenkundig will er ja dass
die kanzlerschaft von angela merkel
vorzeitig endet und möglicherweise
selbst als kanzlerkandidat ins rennen
gehen und es gibt ja einige in der union
die das sehr begrüßen würden hat er da
eine chance nein ich glaube das ist eine
debatte die im moment gerade von älteren
männern geführt wird die vielleicht
nicht ihre karriere ziele erreicht haben
in ihrem leben aber das ist eine sache
die sollten sie mit sich persönlich
ausmachen und das sollten sie jetzt
nicht in die cdu buch eintragen
wir haben die jetzt politische
verantwortung haben wir haben ein ganz
klares zeit tableau das bedeutet dass
wir die kanzlerschaft entscheiden im
dezember 2020 und dieser zeitplan wird
von ernstzunehmenden leuten in der union
auch gar nicht bestritten
naja die junge union gehört jetzt nicht
unbedingt zu den älteren zwar auch zu
älteren männern vielfach aber herr koban
ist
nicht einer der sich jetzt schon sein
ganzes leben an frau merkel ab arbeitet
ja aber trotz alledem fühlt die für die
junge union im moment eine debatte die
genau das gleiche nachvollzieht was die
spd in den abgrund im moment auch treibt
nur personaldebatten urwahlen die eine
partei offenkundig nicht attraktiv
machen
das sind alles debatten die helfen der
union überhaupt nicht weiter und ich
glaube wir sollten uns nicht an der spd
im moment orientieren sondern wir
sollten wieder zu stärke zurückgewinnen
und die menschen wollen von uns
führungsstärke die wollen von uns dass
die probleme diskutiert diskutiert und
auch gelöst werden dass wir den
politischen entscheidungen schneller
werden die menschen dürstet nicht danach
dass parteien sich noch viel aufwendiger
mit personal beschäftigen wäre von daher
wünsche ich mir ausdrücklich auch von
der jungen union eher eine stärkung der
politischen führung als eine schwächung
sagt anja günther fenster präsident von
schleswig-holstein kind für das
interview sehr gerne